it is the nfl draft month as we all know
and this team had some interesting
maneuvers in the
free agency period joining us right in
the middle of the talent
evaluation portion of his non-playing
season as we say it in the nfl is the
head coach of the washington football
team ron rivera back here on the show
how are you coach
doing good rich how are you i am fine uh
what uh walk us through what a uh a day
is like for you getting ready for the
nfl draft ron rivera
well basically it's uh we come in we
have meetings early in the morning with
the coaches or
uh with our uh with our uh scouting
department
uh and then we go back and we start
doing our evals
on uh some of the prospects that uh have
caught our eye
and uh once we get into next week we'll
actually do our draft readings and have
our meetings for the different positions
and uh so we're really you know diving
into it now that uh free agency has
slowed down for the most part
okay yes and you made some interesting
maneuvers let's talk about obviously the
uh
the quarterback spot first up how do you
how do you
evaluate your quarterback room right now
and the depth chart in which you place
everybody right now
well you know the way it's set up you
know ryan's going to come in as as the
starter
um but he's got a he's got a couple of
uh young veteran guys that'll be
competing for uh
for the ability to play up in both
taylor heineken kyle allen
and then we have a a second-year player
coming off of uh a uh disrupted rookie
year stephen montez from colorado who
we we like a lot of but ryan fitzpatrick
comes in
as as a veteran guy he's very savvy uh
and and has a world of experience you
know we're we're a team that i think is
is still developing and growing
and to have a veteran guy leading it
like we did last year with alex
i think it can give us a uh a real big
boost into the development growth of
this football team
and i i mean it's just it is amazing
sometimes watching ryan fitzpatrick play
it's infectious just as a fan
um what about his game do you think
suits washington football team
schemes what do you like about well
really to me it's about ball
distribution
he puts the ball in so many different
players hands you know
uh when we went back and evaluated his
last few years in the league
um they were some of his better years he
did some really good things the last
couple of years
you know he's been very helpful the
growth and development of the team in
miami
and you know here's a guy that can come
in and do the same thing for us
and who knows who knows what happens
after this coming season
um as far as him i mean what he can do
for us and how he can help us grow and
develop as a team
and um what uh
where what where else i guess did you
look at
um how many people did you look at for
your quarterback spot
uh landing on several you know you know
you know we were in the matthew stafford
um um derby
uh you know we we we thought that he
would be a guy that would really help us
as well
and um you know when that when that
didn't transpire you know we had always
been talking about ryan he was always in
the conversation
um and so we went after him uh as soon
as we had the opportunity
and why why ron did uh did things end
with you and
and alex smith it seemed like an
incredible run
um and it it does seem as well like if
you could lend
any any perspective to the way things
ended he wanted to play
maybe uh you didn't you didn't feel
comfortable with him playing in that
playoff game
leading to some sort of gear grinding is
that a fair assessment can what can you
tell us about all that
coach well they're really not much to
talk about as far as that was concerned
i mean it was something that
i i think he felt his opportunities
might lie elsewhere
and so you know we gave him the
opportunity um you know by releasing him
uh and we'll go from there i mean he did
a great job he was very instrumental as
i said in the development of this
football team and
you know he will always have a have a
have a place of high honor here in this
organization and then i guess
i'll give you a chance to maybe respond
he gave a quote to gentleman's quarterly
saying that he thinks that uh his play
helped
lend uh throw a wrench into your plans
and it seemed like you
you actually were quite you know uh
happy to use him sometimes so it was
it was a little bit jarring what do you
say when you hear that
uh quote coach well you know
that you know his site came out and
explained that you know this was a
reporter didn't quite
take it in context which is fine and and
to be honest i i you know he and i had a
great sit down with a great conversation
um um after the season was over and you
know we we talked a little bit about
that
and i told him i said i honestly don't
disagree with you because it was
frightening i told him i was scared to
death
i i did not know um and he said you know
coach that's fair because there really
was no road map to us getting to where
we were
which was true i mean i didn't know what
to expect um
and so because of that you know that
there there was trepidation on my part
and i told him when when he went out
there against the rams and
you know and and and and he gets sacked
for the first time
i had a pit in my stomach and i i
literally turned up into the stands and
looked at his family because i'm
thinking of myself oh goodness you know
what
what's going on um because again there
was no road map
nothing told us you know what was going
to happen so so there was i mean to be
honest to be completely straightforward
about this
um and and as i said we had a great
conversation about it
and and he you know he and i had a good
conversation we really did
ron rivera here uh on the rich eisen
show it seems like you're getting a lot
of some of the
carolina gang back together uh one by
one obviously
you know uh kyle allen is still on your
staff and on i mean on your
on your your roster um you're obviously
comfortable with him and how he can run
an offense that you're comfortable with
and curtis samuel
you went out and uh and acquired him in
free agency
uh what what do you what do you like
about curtis's game and how you think it
can
fit into everything that you're
obviously building there on the o for
the wft
well i think it's exciting because what
it gives us is it gives us a
a a a vertical compliment to who
um terry mclaurin is for us
you know with with terry now out there
and curtis out there and and
and and the mixture of guys that that we
have that we could put in
into play for ourselves you know uh with
adam humphries and
and and some of the guys are coming back
as far as cam sims is concerned and
stephen sims
i mean we have an array of guys that can
contribute
and really uh go out there and and and
tell people hey you can't roll to carry
anymore you can't double terry
anymore um because if you do and you
want to leave curtis alone then great
that's why we'll take it or you want to
leave logan thomas alone
you know or or cam sims or you know uh
any of the guys we have weapons now and
and that i think is one of the more
important things that we have people
that
need to have the ball in their hands and
you know again that's why i said that's
the idea behind bringing the guy like
ryan fitzpatrick in
a guy that can distribute the ball to
the different people
ron rivera here on the rich eisen show
so
uh what are you let's talk a little bit
about some of the rule changes that uh
might be coming in the nfl or being
discussed in the nfl
um or were discussed in the nfl do you
like the idea of a sky judge
coach would you be upset um i i do i i
think
you know whatever we can do to to to
help
and make sure we get it right i think
that's important and yet there's still a
lot of things that have to be worked out
and i know those will be things that
will be discussed
uh as as we start having our meetings um
in the next couple of weeks as far as
you know deciding whether or not that
something we do on a permanent basis or
you know or for a trial basis
but i i do like the idea of doing what
we can to make sure we get it right
because it's important i mean
you know these games are important you
know it's not like baseball or
basketball where you have a number of
games
you know we have a limited number we
have you know we're now 17 that you have
to play
and and you want to win as many as those
you can i think it's important that you
get them right and if this helps us then
great
are you going to change the way that you
run practices
coach uh and any way shape or form now
that there's a 17th regular season game
uh i think so i i i think we learned a
lot from last year
to be upfront about that um you know as
we went along the year
and how things were changing and how
things were you know were being required
of us to be done
um i think we may have found a couple of
things completely different from what
i've done in the past as i did carolina
my last few years
um in terms of of practice practice reps
number of reps time spent on the field
um
time spent and and walkthroughs time
spent and actual action periods
i mean all that really came into play
and i think we learned
um at least i i feel like we learned um
you know myself
our training staff our strength
conditioning and our coaches
just how important it is to to be aware
of these
so uh i i do think it's gonna it's it's
gonna change the way we approach to
the the the season as as as we go
through this 17 game stretch
would dicker have changed his approach
if you had a 17th game back in the 80s
coach um i think he would have okay
i do because i i know he changed i know
he adopted um when we went to 16.
okay um and and i know he would have
adopted
uh as as we go along you know he
he's somebody that paid attention to
those things um
yeah did we practice physically yes we
did
but as the season went on we tapered off
so so
i think he would have done the same
thing what's the angriest you ever made
him or saw him
oh man i remember one time um
we blocked a kick and
we tried to scoop it and
and i missed it and another player
missed it
and they recovered it and it was a you
know because it was a change of
possession of however worked out
right um it ended up as a first down for
the opponent
and so we had to go back out there for
for
another series thank goodness we stopped
them but when we were coming off
dika was there waiting for us yeah he
he's just right away he yelled we have
too many
blankety-blank heroes just fall on the
ball
and i still remember that to this day i
mean i imagine you coach the same thing
maybe in a different manner but
uh you carry that with you and you try
to
you try to instruct your charges in that
regard i'm sure
oh man i do remember that holy cow
i didn't mean to give you those
flashbacks but i i you i heard you tell
this story in a zoom that we did
uh together with uh with tarico and a
whole bunch of guys for
for our our friends at wheels up a
couple of uh months ago and i i'd love
to
for the super bowl i'd love to have you
retell it about john madden and how
influential he was in in in i guess
helping
you um you know in a way earn your
reputation as the old riverboat ron can
you walk me through that one what a
great story this
is if you don't mind yeah hitting me on
this one well what would happen was
you know after my second season i had
this dubious
record of being three and 13 of games
cited by six points or less
and uh the former owner jerry richardson
had told me you know you need a mentor
um i have a friend named john madden who
you know
he said i've talked with him and he's
waiting to hear from you so i
so i called coach and and and we started
talking and he said
oh by the way before you come see me you
know those 13 games you lost
i said yeah he said go back and look at
those games and and think about what you
could have done differently
so i did i went back i looked at those
13 games i wrote this beautiful report
okay it's like about 18 pages
of details about what i could have done
differently and how things could have
changed if i'd done these different
things
so we set an appointment i fly out to
see a
coach uh in his home office in pleasant
california
i come in we sit down we start talking
and i mean it was interesting a second
so just as we're about to get into the
nuts and bolts of our conversation i
said hey coach
i got that report for it he's oh cool
um but it's not for me that's for you i
said excuse me so that's for you
what did you learn well i said the
biggest thing i learned is i i i went by
the book
he said you went by the book what book i
said you know the one you know i mean
you should kick you here in this
situation like you know this game
you know and and he said yeah how'd it
turn out
i said well he goes ron forget this book
to go by your good instinct you played
enough football you coached enough
football
to go by your gut go by how the game
feels
do those things and so
i thought about that go back and now we
start the 2013 season
and we're playing buffalo and buffalo
and we get into the same situation and
sure enough
i went by the book we kicked it go up by
six
they get the ball drive down score the
touchdown kicks here's the point and
they beat us by one
i was sick i was ready to throw up on
again everything kept flashing back to
what coach said to me
and so i'm driving home that night
monday night i've watched the tape about
ten times and just saw you sick
as i'm driving i'm thinking about this i
run a red light and i almost get t-boned
and it just just oh it just wakes me up
and i'm thinking oh my god
i get home and i just and i can't get i
can't shake it
so the next week we're playing the
giants at home
in our first series okay we were on two
at that time
in our first series i go for it twice on
fourth down both times we convert
and score the touchdown and then from
that point on every time we got into a
fourth down situation
thinking about down in distance and
where we on the field
we went for it we went for it and so as
as
as the games progressed by about the
fifth game of the season um i did it
again
we played minnesota in minnesota on the
first series it's four
two we were on a shovel pass to mike
tobert he scores the touchdown
so after the game some reporter
basically writes
boy ron rivera he went for it he gave he
was gambling like a like a riverboat
gambler
and that's how it was born riverboat ron
and you know
and it's really not necessarily about
just throwing you know to the wind as
much as it's really thinking about
calculating situations like that and
that's how riverboat ron was born and
you won
you went on an eight-game winning streak
off of that and then obviously a couple
of coach of the year
awards after that and now here you are
the defending nfc's champion head coach
the washington football team and uh i
just just to
dovetail off that just a little bit is
is is what
what the role of analytics plays now
you see it all the time i mean you went
you you went you went for the two-point
conversion in the win against the giants
that almost you know when it all came
that let the giants you know root
heavily for jalen hurts against you on
sunday night football in game 256 you
know like so
so how what what what is that push pull
that you deal with
sometimes it it's really it's about
momentum and and
and and stuff like that to me you know
it's funny because
you know i i've had i've had coaches
that i work mentors like like
like north turner and norman i have
talked about you know the right time to
go for it on two
you know like a lot of people say well
if you're down by fourteen and you score
you should go for two now
okay and on your first score
well if you do that you just got the
momentum back
and now you go for two and you miss now
you've lost the momentum
you know what i'm saying so i mean those
are the things that norm and i talked
about
and so i've always tried to keep those
types of things in mind and and how you
do it so really
it's about gut feel to me i i think the
analytics are there to really
i guess just indicate whether or not you
know
this is the right time timer this is a
good time to do it you know what i'm
saying
because because i've had situations
where when we've gone for it
with the analytics and it didn't happen
out
and i've been told hey that's okay you
did what was what the analytics said
and to me i struggle with that because
if i do what analytics said
and it says nine times out of ten you're
gonna complete it there's that one time
out of ten you don't
you know what i'm saying yes and and and
and so how do you know if you're gonna
be that one time out of 10 that doesn't
that isn't successful you don't say
i mean if if there's is no guarantee you
can tell me all you want oh that
it's 99 hey that's good yeah but what if
you're that one percent what's that one
time it doesn't work nobody talks about
that
until it happens right and then it's off
a bad decision no it's not a bad
decision the numbers
yeah but the numbers also said so you
just don't know you can argue
it all you want you could for sure hey
before i let you go i know you've been
kind enough to call
in uh i just one this is this is
literally for me i'm not gonna lie here
the the most exciting play one of the
most exciting places let's put it that
way in the in the postseason was taylor
heinecke
diving for the pylon hitting the hitting
the pylon hitting hitting it with the
heineken
and uh in that in that game against uh
tampa it was
it was dynamite uh i i i hate the rule
that if the ball is fumbled into the end
zone it goes back to the defense i
hate that because again because taylor
if if taylor had lost the ball
on the way to that pylon he's making an
aggressive play it got me off the couch
it was
so exciting what what do you what do you
think of that rule would you want it
changed in the nfl no no because
because there's always that caveat that
if i always risk it by putting the ball
out and putting the ball out and putting
the ball out right
okay i always risk that then there is
there is no penalty for the risk
nothing can be risk-free there has to be
a penalty
you know it's crazy it's like it's like
when when we go through when we go
through
um um training camp and we got a rookie
that's making all these plays on on
defense and everything like that because
god is going to be a great quarterback
and i always say not so fast i said what
do you mean not so fast i see
practically no consequences
i said when you watch these some of
these guys play during practice they're
great there's no consequence they get on
the field now everything's in front of
them
they get tackled all this stuff and
everybody goes man went up to that guy
that we had training
well there's no consequences in training
so when it's for real
and there's consequences now they may
not always be sticking that ball out
because there's there should always be
that chance that that
they may lose that ball it may cost them
that's that's why to me it's hard for me
to sit there and say oh yeah we should
change the rule
well again if there's no consequences
people are gonna they're gonna try and a
good deal
well there's nothing to help the defense
then well this is like past interference
the guy throws the ball up in the air 50
yards downfield
and these guys are hand fighting and the
referee decides to call it a defense
apparently the ball is on the one
whereas whereas if if if if they call it
on the offense but
it's from where it's from where the ball
was thrown that's where the penalty goes
from
well but my issue is is that if the ball
if let's just say taylor reaches for it
and
it gets fumbled out at the half inch
yard line it's still yours but if it's
fumbled another 16 inches
north it's no longer yours that seems to
me totally arbitrary that that that i
can't stand
i mean that so i i would change it that
could be a reverse touchback that you
now get the ball on the 20 with the same
down the distance is obviously different
but it's the same down so there is some
risk i just don't like the fact that the
defense that's been bending and is about
to break gets a break
because the guy loses the ball in the
end zone even if they did even if they
did force the fumble defensively if it
goes out at the half-inch yard line it's
still yours
further up the field it's not that's the
that's the arbitrariness i don't like
wow no hey that's that's why that's why
it's great to have a
a talk show because we can talk about
well the ron rivera show coming up after
the rich eisen show everybody
thanks for the call ron i appreciate the
time immensely certainly during a busy
time of the year for you i'm sure we'll
chat again soon
thank you all right thank you guys
that's ron rivera everybody the hc
of the wft hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here